la route ces premiers millions l'armée
comme la bêta non ses désirs le
président de la république apporte son
concours ils seront six mille mobilisés
sur place
on est encore loin de toute cette
logistique puisque nous enlever spéciaux
en charente-maritime olivier galzi
nathalie galère ont eu du mal à trouver
les sauveteurs en uniforme en revanche
l'éleveur ils ont parfois été très
surpris la tempête a laissé derrière
elle des images insolites des situations
qui raconte à elle seule la violence de
l'événement et l'impuissance des ogres
ici dans l'estuaire de la gironde
ce cargo poser comme une feuille douche
l'entrée d'un port
ce soir les habitants de cette ferme
repartiront en barque ils ne dormiront
pas chez eux ils sont plusieurs
centaines
dans cette situation
laurent lui n'a pas voulu quitter sa
ferme mais il est isolé presque coupée
du reste du monde depuis deux jours
la tempête n'a laissé ici que désolation
en fait ce qu'on peut on essaie dans la
journée de nettoyage qui a peu d'éclat
nuit tombe avait plus rien à faire à
temps et puis voilà vous avez pas d'eau
pas d'électricité
ainsi de nombreux tableaux potter là les
pompiers puis dormir se fait de nuire un
beau tellement envie de dormir
et si les pompiers distribuent de l'eau
l'armée elle prête son matériel les
hommes du 6e régiment du génie sont à
pied d'oeuvre depuis aujourd'hui
aulas ici on a engagé un moyen
polyvalent de juni 1 pg et ont fait
ouverte une erreur et rétablissement
date en fait le but de la séquence a
libéré les lignes c d aider à libérer
les lignes pour l'edf qui doit rétablir
le courant plus vite et ensuite
rétablir les axes pour les personnes
cinq engins comme celui-ci et 17 hommes
en tout pour le département entier les
moyens mis en oeuvre par est cependant
bien faible demain d'autres renforts
militaires sont attendus
ils devront livrer la bataille de l'eau
et de l'électricité dans les zones les
plus isolées dans de nombreux endroits
du département l'hélicoptère reste le
meilleur moyen d'accéder aux zones
sinistrées
et justement parce qu'il ya plusieurs
endroits comme celui-ci coupé du monde
il est difficile à l'heure actuelle de
mesurer l'ampleur exacte des dégâts cela
prendra plusieurs jours plusieurs jours
pendant lesquels nombre d'habitants de
charente-maritime seront privés d'eau et
d'électricité